hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round four of the 2020 Tata
Steel masters edition it's Wesley so in
the world Fisher random champion against
Alvarez Afrojack who's been having an
excellent tournament so far he is
currently in the lead and it's it's a
remarkable game so it's not a surprise
that a lot of you have suggested it and
well without further ado let's check out
the game and if you if you haven't
checked it out do check out I was a
guest on Ben Johnson's podcast so the
links to the podcast will be in the
description below if you maybe miss the
previous video and missed the
announcement so that being said let's
check out the game wesley with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have d5 c4 and
already sorry about that and already
some action from the beginning d
captures on c4 other as it goes for the
queen's gambit accepted now if there are
if there are some beginners watching the
video it's been a while since we've had
a queen's gambit accepted I will just
shortly mention that if you encounter
this do not defend the pony if you try
playing it because if white goes after
the pony it's better just to give it
away if you're a beginner because if you
try and defend that you can run into
something like a 4 c6 captures captures
and Queen f3 and you lose the rook so
there are a lot of tricky ideas in the
Queens gambit accepted so don't play it
if you're if you're not sure what you're
doing
so Knight to f3 by Wesley we have Knight
to f6 and now III preparing to win back
the pond and of course our is I just
continues development east 6 Bishop
captures on c4 and now c5 striking in
the center as you should
we have castles by Wesley and now a six
now we're b3 Wesley prepares to
fianchetto the dark squared Bishop and
now see characters on d4 we had a knife
captures on d4 and Bishop to e7 alavesa
came very well prepared as he's
following the game obviously so already
played again shot in my media in the
Vita Grand Prix played in Riga last year
so the shop the b2 a continuing
development both bishops are now nicely
developed eyeing that King side with
castles by Alireza
and now Knight study 2 was played here
when mama when West
played against my media of in the Grand
Prix in Riga but here he goes Busch back
to e too hard to say where it's to avoid
all it is a preparation or he just
prefers prefers this line now so Bishop
to d7 Alvarez again continues
development Knights the D to end the
night the c6 and here there is a game
that reached this position it was
actually from the grand Swiss tournament
last year bus car and a busker an odd
even versus Hikaru Nakamura where Bishop
the F theory was played by a demon and
that game ended in a draw but here we
have looked the c1 by Wesley and it is a
new move as moved 12 so we have a
completely new game now and Wesley
really loves new games he is the world
official random champion so he does
really care if he's in preparation out
of preparation he just enjoys playing in
every position which he proved by
beating everyone in the face random
World Championship so look the c8 also
you want to put a rock on the open file
and now tonight back there three Wesley
avoids some unnecessary unnecessary
trades and makes it hard for ali reza to
employ his bishops with b5 and now a
three taking away the be four square
from black's pieces Queen to b6
developing a preparing maybe maybe two
double rooks on the C file if the
position allows it and also just
connecting rooks and here Wesley has to
figure out how to continue development
how to improve his position now he wants
to double rooks on the C file the way to
do this he wants to play rook c2 and
bring the rook over to c1 so he has to
put the bishop on d3 put the Queen honey
to and then make a rook lift and bring
the other look over to C 1 so if he can
do this then his position will be great
rook to c2 he starts with this plan and
now e v with ideas of maybe pushing it
all the way to e4 so Wesley prevented by
Bishop to d3 now both night and Bishop
Guardia Foursquare and he makes room for
the Queen on e2 will look after d8 and
now getting the Queen away from that
defiled by playing Queen te - this all
works well into his plan of doubling
rooks on the C file and the Bishop to g4
now so here you have to check if there
are any tricks for example if if black
could remove the
of the d3 bishop that would be that
would be great but it doesn't work so
obviously just doubles rooks on the C
file and here you have to decide what to
do and it's really we could say that
this is one of the critical moments in
the position so Alvarez I decided to
play tonight the a7 here which makes
sense the two rooks are incredibly
strong on the C file so the knight
really can't move just anywhere
otherwise you're gonna get real
characters and see it okay the bishop is
still here but you can always play h3
force the bishop to either move or or to
capture so it's not not pleasant for
black so all it s the decides to go for
a knife to a7 and yeah this is one with
the positions where you actually don't
want the trade material I move like
Queen to b7 should be preferred keeping
the tension but who would who would play
such a move I mean it's uh it's really
hard to find such moves he played nice
the a7 which is a principled move makes
sense white controls more space you want
to trade down and what would you do here
in this position if you were Wesley I
just give the position some thought
pause the video and try to figure out
what you would play well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those who were
able to do it congratulations you are on
your way on becoming a super Grandmaster
you know perhaps we'll see how it goes
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show now here Wesley shows us
how how simple elite chess really is
he goes through captures on c8 we have
rook after solid as a rock a person c8
Knight captures and now h3 and this is
what elite chess is all about and here
Wesley says I'm winning the bishop pair
so if you could capture on e5 but then
you just trade the e5 point for the a
three point Wesley wants at all Wesley
says h3 and now if you move the bishop
then I can just pick up the e5 pawn with
my knight as the spin no longer exists
if I go bareback just g4 by white is
sufficient again you will be able to
pick up the pawn so here all eraser has
to give up the bishop pair we have not
Knight captures if Knight captures you
allow this and Alireza wins material so
Queen captures on f3 and now a Wesley
wins the bishop
there so this is what he wanted we have
Queen to d8 putting pressure on the
bishop the bishop cannot move as the
knight is also undefended
so Queen back to e two we have Queen
Queen to d5 and excellent centralizing
move by alavesa putting pressure on the
b3 pawn as well so Bush rook to c2
getting the bishop out of harm's way
also adding another defender to the b3
pawn we have nice 2d6 now improving the
the position of the night and now Queen
to d3 Wesley says yeah let's trade
Queens here he also puts a lot of
pressure on the Andy h7 pawn so then the
knight will be unable to move Alireza
here decides to trade Queens Queen
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
to d7 with ideas of maybe pushing f5
could be could be great if you could get
this in so Wesley prevents it
immediately with the g4 we have g6 by
ali reza and now Knight to e4 offering
further trades others accepts with
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
tonight the c5 putting pressure on the
bishop and the b3 pawn so Wesley defends
both red special back to see - and hear
the the way to go about this is to go f6
and then slowly but surely bring the
King into the game early there's a place
a more committal move he plays d4 which
allows Wesley to actually win this pawn
so Wesley starts with b4 it doesn't win
the pawn right away since early days of
course goes night to d3 he wants
captures captures and then this point
will be very strong for example King F 1
Bishop h4 and now this pawn is weak and
well you can never pull the pawn because
now the Bishop and pawn will create a
wall so the White King will not be able
to cross it it would be it would be an
equal position but it was Lee says nope
I'm not trading the bishop pair just yet
he goes brush up the c3 and now ali reza
has to start start something either
bringing the king into the game or or
deciding how to go about the position
first he goes kink to f8 he starts with
us with king f1 and now f5 the e4 pawn
is now defended the problem is it
doesn't really help black because Wesley
just plays King - E - and
well even though the point is now
defended you cannot move the night all
of the squares are taken away from the
Black Knight so you you have to just
allow Wesley to capture the night so
Bishop to d8 with Bishop captures and e3
pawn captures and King captures on d3
and here it's a Wesley's upon up and
it's an endgame of bishops of the same
color so unless it's like a very special
position or or white or black puts up
some insane defense you know the general
consensus is white white should be able
to win this so King if seven and now II
for grabbing more space with the King
and here F for seems to be a more
resilient defense however our Reza goes
for captures captures and now g5 the
idea being that he says that okay the
white king will not be able to cross
because if King F evening before there
should be six will pick up the f2 pawn
but Wesley says that pawn is nothing
compared to the activity of my king so
he pushes King before and now you have
to play it better be six checks King d5
Bishop captures and then out King to c6
and now you cannot defend these pawns
here as they are on light squares
whereas west responds are also on light
squares so there will not be targets and
if you look at this now for example all
of these squares are covered so the
entire fifth rank is basically a wall
the black king will not be able to cross
so you know the black King can never
cross this so white is just free to pick
up all the points here so King e6 that's
e7 King e6 going after after the white
king goes after the a6 pawn the black
King will try to defend the b5 point so
King b7 King the 7 and now King captures
on a6 came to c6 now defending but now
II 5 by Wesley now preparing to push the
pawn and again we reach a very beautiful
moment in the game where it is a place
Bishop to e3 it seemed it seems
impossible to stop the pond but actually
Bishop to g3 is a is a is a valiant
attempt a point being that after a 6 and
Bishop to d6
yes you have brush up to f6 guarding the
pawn here but
h6 guarding this point here we have e 7
King to d7 and now King captures on b5
finally Bishop captures on e7 Bishop
captures King captures and now you get
this position where it's three against
two but black but after white starts
pushing you have h5 and now it becomes
really interesting G captures on h5 g
for now black starts pushing the
passport and now not a five but h6 this
is the crucial move to find in this line
point being that h6 you're much closer
to the queening square king f6 h7 King
g7 and now a five starting to push this
pawn and after g3 now you play h8 Queen
and this is very important because it
brings the King to the back rank and now
you will Queen your pawn with check and
this is super important a six G to a
seven just preparing to Queen the pawn
g1 Queen but now a eight queen with
check and now after you move the King
it's again white to move and you will
you know do your stuff do your best to
trade to trade the Queen's off and then
Queen this pawn and win the game so
really really beautiful line so I
decided to show it I hope you don't mind
no but yeah Bishop to g3 was a valiant
attempt but loses by force so Bishop to
e3 by ali reza we east six by wesley now
bishop the c1 going after the a3 pawn
and now you could push east 7 e7 king d7
can capture son b5 and now after Bishop
captures on a3 just Bishop to f6
defending everything h6 defending g5 and
now King a for you push the bishop back
start pushing this pawn and again it
will be completely winning for white so
we have a different attempt by Wesley
instead of Easton he goes for a four
it's really just remarkable how precise
Wesley is B captures on if an a4 and now
Bishop to e5 insane move because it
takes away all the squares from the
black King this squared this squared the
pawn takes the square the King takes
this square and you cannot approach
anywhere to help out with the stopping
of the pawn so here it was in this
position on move 47 that other eyes of
Rosa resigned the game
and this is his first loss of the
tournament whereas for Wesley Wesley
takes sole lead after this game point is
that whatever you play a three doesn't
really matter you have b5 check and now
you force the King back so all of these
squares are not available to the black
King you have to go back in c5 now East
seven and white is just much faster if
well also D a 1 square is covered so you
have to play something like Bishop b2
not just a queen you have a queen black
doesn't and it's just game over
so after Bishop to e5 ali reza frota
resigned and an excellent a victory for
Wesley so and here you can see how how
simple elite chess really is Wesley just
played that rook exchange along the C
file 1 the bishop affair and then with
the bishop pair he was able to
outmaneuver - it's not that the game was
winning because Wesley had the bishop
pair it's just that well unless you're
like Magnus or someone the bishop pair
really is to be preferred and just just
almost always are out plays all the
other pieces but yeah here are the
standings so we don't forget that there
you have it Wesley so so lead with three
out of four followed by several people
between the two and a half Jeffrey's
young Fabiano Caruana ali reza phir aaja
Jordan went forest and Vladislav Artemia
then with two points Magnus cross and
onigiri and young shift of Duda who drew
all four of their games so maybe now
that that Magnus no longer has to worry
about his unbeaten streak maybe he's
just gonna you know go crazy we'll see
what happens then oh sorry ended the
Neil dubov but he he won't one game in
lost one game with one and a half we
have an Akita B to commend Vishwanathan
Anand with one und and the vladislav
Korolev with half a point out of four
here you can see Co a living would have
a point out of four just though the
difference between the challengers
edition and the Masters Edition as he is
the last year's winner winner of the
challengers edition and now opened five
out of four I really you know puts into
perspective the challengers and the
Masters edition yeah
sure about a long outro that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Frank Holmes
me
a COBOL chick Joe Wilkinson my [ __ ] list
and Ben Johnson for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the type of
steel tournament the the Women's World
Chess Championship match and well of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day